all right I'm back I'm going to show you
a very powerful acupressure technique
it's just really a pressure technique on
the back of your neck in a certain place
that will pop open your sinuses if you
have congestion or your sinuses are not
draining and you're going to feel
wonderful because you're going to
breathe again so uh in practice I use
this technique on thousands of people
with great success and I'm going to show
you how to do it now I do want to
mention a couple things about the
sinuses because this is an acupressure
technique and there's other things that
can cause the sinus problem like fungus
growing in your sinuses bacterial
infection etc etc and also an allergy to
cheese okay so cheese is probably the
biggest culprit so if you have a sinus
problem just avoid cheese and see if
that doesn't just clear it up and of
course sugar feeds the unfriendly fungus
and yeast that are in the sinuses and
just avoiding that would probably help
you greatly I did a video on using a
couple drops of diluted kimchi juice
that works really good on reestablishing
the normal microbes in your sinuses and
of course Spanish black radish is a good
remedy for Sun's problems okay you have
two options okay you can either
get a device like this my device and use
this on the back of your neck or you can
get someone to watch this video and just
apply the technique so I'm going to show
you both ways but I first have to tell
you how I came up with this okay
so when I was in chiropractic school
um unfortunately in the very beginning
part when you start learning about
technique you have to practice this and
who are you going to practice on right
other students so you get to practice
another students and then these other
new students get to practice on you I'm
talking adjusting the neck right and so
you have people that
do not have a clue of what they're doing
and they start working on adjustments
and so someone adjusted me uh
incorrectly and I ended up with
stuffiness if I couldn't breathe and so
I went to the instructor and at that
time uh it was a very famous
chiropractor named Virgil Strang if you
know anything about chiropractor you
know we're just Strang he wrote
philosophy books he's a very competent
seasoned chiropractor been in practice
for many years he's probably one of the
best adjusters that I ever had work on
me so he checked me and he said oh
um we need to work on C2 okay that's the
second vertebrae here so we felt it he
found out it was rotated the wrong way
he did it the opposite way and just
popped open my sinuses and I could
finally breathe after several days of
having a stuffy nose so I will say
there's nothing better than having a
competent chiropractor work on you and
do the exact right procedure okay but of
course when you're learning you have
people uh rubbing you or adjusting you
the wrong way now in practice I had this
idea instead of adjusting this vertebra
right here the second one
could it work if you just applied
pressure and what I found was it does
work very dramatically and so when
you're done with this video I want you
to have someone do this to you if you
have a sinus problem and then write in
the comments on what happened because
you're going to find a huge shift in
your ability to breathe but the first
thing I want you to do is just to check
your sinuses and plug one sinus and then
see which sinus is open which one is
closed and just kind of get in a
conceptual idea of how bad it is because
then you want to re-rate it and see how
much better it is but you should feel
great relief immediately applying
pressure to the second vertebra now the
question is why does it work
um I don't know because
the nerves that control the sinuses okay
are part of the cranial nerves which are
higher up
in in the brain stem like right in the
occiput way over here it doesn't
necessarily extend down into these this
area of the body that I know of but
there could be some type of connection I
just don't know all I know is when you
press into this area Okay correctly
you can cause a great opening of the
sinuses okay and I'm going to show you
how to do it to someone else and then
that person can do it to you you want to
take your thumb and your middle finger
right here okay I'm not flipping you off
but you want to press into okay directly
from the back part called the posterior
to the anterior you want to directly put
pressure right here I usually like to
have the person sitting down and I like
to kind of um get my elbow right here
and press this way so I'm not like out
like this okay so I kind of like to get
behind and I like to have them sitting
down but I have the skeleton standing so
it's a little difficult but anyway
you're going to press right here so this
is you apply your fingers about this
wide okay
now how do you find it right underneath
the skull you drop right down
the first one you're going to feel is
the first one okay you just drop down
about I'd say maybe
three-fourths of an inch okay maybe an
inch below this back part here it's
called the back of the skull occiput so
you drop down about an inch and you'll
be right at the second
cervical vertebra
and you're going to just apply pressure
now you're going to take your other hand
and put in the forehead so you're not
just pressing this way right so you take
the forehead let's show you right here
hold that
and then you press in this way this
pressure right here okay so you just
press it doesn't have to be that hard
and hold okay the key is making sure
that the pressure on this finger and
this thumb is equal
okay and just going to hold that
for maybe 20 seconds to 30 seconds
and you're just going to ask the person
tell me when you can start breathing
again
and probably within 10 15 seconds
they're going to go wow I can breathe
better right so if you do it longer
you'll have more Improvement
so that's the Simplicity of how to do
this technique now if you have my device
you can use the medium width one and you
can put it right in the back of the neck
and lay on a tall back chair or a couch
I do this every night and I put pressure
there and I allow the gravity
to press in the back part of the C2 the
second cervical vertebra and I'll just
hold it there and it'll just
allow me to breathe that helps with
other things too but those are the two
different ways you can use this simple
acupressure to open up your sinuses so
what I want you to do right now is get
someone to do this to you if you have
sinus problems or you do it to someone
else and comment Down Below on how it
helped you and then when you're done
with that
I recommend you watch this video right
here the one that you're applying a
couple drops of kimchi to really help
you improve your sinus microbiome when I
put that video up right here check it
out